what kind of love do you want to send to
Jamie as he is you know dealing with
nothing but love for Jamie I mean I wish
him the besties in my prayers every
night
um he's not only one of our best
entertainers we have out here but he's a
great person and um he's a genuine
person so please pray for him and
continue to show him lots of love have
you heard from him do you have you sent
a prayer oh man I heard he's in Atlanta
that's crazy
I've been out here though since uh last
week
but if I go back man I'm gonna go find
my brother and check on him man I don't
even really know what happened man I was
just stunned because Jamie's fit oh this
dude ain't no you know he don't do
nothing man this dude is fit so I was
really concerned man so I hope
everything works out I'm pretty sure it
will man yeah the way I found out about
Jamie was on Martin's page when Martin
posted and you know Martin doesn't post
personal things and when I saw that post
I became a little alarm but then I said
let me just do a little more digging and
um yeah I didn't know nothing really
came up so I just automatically prayed
for Jamie Jamie's such a good human
being great person does a lot for a lot
of people
um and I just pray for his strength when
you hear something like that you just
you're human instinct you just pray you
pray and wish for the best so I pray
that Jamie pulls through whatever he's
going through I love Jamie Jamie is a
good friend of mine as a matter of fact
the other day I threw one up for him in
the air so prayer my prayers go up for
Jamie
and he's struggling he's a fighter he's
going to come out of it he's good he's
going to be stronger and better than
ever
he never would have made it without God
we all need God in our lives
yeah I've been there I was on the other
side in a coma for 10 days so I know
about that
and I just want Jamie to please get
strong Jamie I love you my prayers go
out to you and your family please get
well
[Music]